one of my favorite
stories involving marvin minsky is
when i asked him about
how he was able to turn out so many
fantastic
phds so many fantastic people who did
great phd theses
how did he think of all these great
ideas what he said is
he would generally say something
that didn't exactly make sense he didn't
really know what it meant
but the student
would figure like oh my god minsky said
this it must be a great idea and he'll
sweat he or she would work on work and
work until they found some meaning in
this sort of chauncey gardener-like
utterance that minsky had made
and then some great thesis would come
out of it yeah i love this so much
because there's uh young people come up
to me
and i i'm distinctly made aware that the
words i say have a long lasting impact i
will now start doing the minsky method
of saying something uh cryptically
profound
and then letting them actually
uh make something useful and great out
of that
you have to become
revered enough that people will take as
a default that everything you say is
profound yes exactly exactly i mean i
love marvin miske so much there's so
much uh i've i've heard this interview
with him where he said that uh the key
to his success has been to hate
everything he's ever done
like in the past
he has so many good like one-liners and
just um
or also
uh to work on things that nobody else is
working on because he's not very good at
doing stuff oh i i think that was just
false well but see i took whatever he
said and i ran with it and i thought it
was profound because it's more of a
misca no
a lot of behavior is in the eye of the
beholder and a lot of the meaning is in
the eye of the beholder one of uh
minsky's early programs was begging
program are you familiar with this
so this was back in the day when you had
job control cards
at the beginning of your ibm card deck
that said things like how many cpu
seconds to allow this to run before it
got kicked off and
because computer time was enormously
expensive and so he wrote a program and
all it did was
um it said you know give me uh 30
seconds of cpu time and all it did was
it would wait like 20 seconds and then
it would print out on the operator's
console teletype
i need another 20 seconds so the
operator would give it another 20
seconds it would wait it says i'm almost
done i needed a little bit more time
so at the end he'd get this printout and
he'd be charged you know for like 10
times as much computer time as this job
control card you know and he'd say look
i put 10 seconds you know 30 seconds
here um you're charging me for five
minutes i'm not going to pay for this
and the poor operator would say well the
program kept asking for more time and
marvin would say oh it always does that
i love that is is there if you could
just linger on it for a little bit is
there something you've learned from
your interaction with marvinski about
artificial intelligence about life
uh but i mean he's again
like your work his work is uh
you know he's a seminal figure in the in
this very short history of artificial
intelligence
research and development
what have you learned from him as a
human being as a
as an ai
intellect
i would say both he and ed feigenbaum
impressed on me the
the realization that
our lives are finite our research lives
are finite we're going to have limited
opportunities
to do
ai research projects so you should make
each one count
don't be afraid of doing a project
that's going to take years
or even decades
to and
don't
settle for bump on a log projects
that could lead to some you know
published
journal article
that five people will read and pat you
on the head for and and so on so
one bump on a log after another is not
how you get from the earth to the moon
by slowly putting additional bumps on
this log the only way to get there is to
think about the hard problems and think
about novel solutions to them and if you
do that
if you're
willing to
listen to
nature to empirical reality willing to
be wrong
it's perfectly fine because if
occasionally you're right
then you've gotten part of the way to
the moon
you